Texas
you know is very attractive to many
Californians a lot of people fleeing
that state the U-Hauls are all moving in
One Direction We fled we didn't go to
Texas but we went kind of close we went
to Tennessee
well there's a major Californian
who is leaving for Texas now that would
be Governor Gavin Newsom
uh sorry Texans Democrat Governor Gavin
Newsom spoke at an event in Texas over
the weekend and this would not be
particularly noteworthy
politicians speak all over the country
all the time Gavin Newsom obviously
wants to run for president no surprise
that he's holding events in different
states except that
travel to Texas is explicitly banned
government traveled to Texas is banned
by California and it's banned by
California because Texas doesn't want to
trans the kids
there in 27 there was a measure that
went into effect in California
that took action because of North
Carolina's measures to keep the men in
the men's bathroom and the women in the
women's bathroom and it says that it
voids or repeals or has the effect of
voiding or repealing existing state or
local protect oh I'm sorry any state
that Voyager appeals or has the effect
of voiding or repealing existing state
or local protections against
discrimination on the basis of sexual
orientation gender identity or gender
expression uh those States you cannot
travel to as a government official
in California
so Gavin Newsom does it now Gavin
newsom's already done this kind of stuff
before he did it back uh over the summer
he went on a vacation to Montana Montana
is also one of these states and Newsome
said oh it's not a big deal it's not a
big deal no it's I it was just a
personal trip even though he brought his
security team with him no no it was a
personal trip so it doesn't count now
Gavin Newsom obviously knew that this
was a problem with the California law
because he didn't include the trip to
Montana on his schedule so he knew it
was a big issue he did it anyway
this is certainly violating that law
going to Texas doesn't matter he did it
anyway
why did he do it because the rules don't
apply to him and none of us are
surprised
we know how there is there are two
systems of Justice in this country
and conservatives have the harsher one
right we're the ones who the libs can go
around and burn the country down for
eight months that's fine they get a slap
on the wrist if that conservatives if we
peacefully protest outside of an
abortion clinic we're going to have two
dozen gestapo agents kick in our door
and point rifles at us in front of our
seven kids that's just that's just the
way it works now Donald Trump
perfectly legally bring some documents
after he was president to Mar-A-Lago
what happens the Gestapo knocked down
the door and they raid the president's
home
but
right left-wing officials face no
consequences whatsoever frequently for
doing the very same thing we know that
we know that that happens and so
bringing you right back to thinking
about Edward Snowden you think well I I
love my country
but I can't say that I really like these
people who are running the country
because not only are they doing it in an
incompetent way in an unjust way in an
immoral way but they're actually coming
after me okay
they're coming after me for believing
perfectly ordinary things like don't
kill babies and don't trans the kids
it's just lawlessness and you're seeing
that lawlessness especially from Gavin
Newsom
Gavin Newsom is now
issuing government ID cards
to illegal aliens says we're a state of
Refuge a majority minority state where
27 percent of us are immigrants that's
why I'm proud to announce the signing of
today's bills to further support our
immigrant Community which makes our
state stronger every single day and
here's what the new law says the bill
would specify that immigration
enforcement as defined does not
constitute an Urgent health and safety
need for those purposes and would
prohibit a government agency or
Department law enforcement agency
commercial entity or other person from
obtaining accessing using or otherwise
disclosing the non-criminal history
information maintained by the department
for the purpose of immigration
enforcement they're saying not only are
we going to give these immigrants these
illegal aliens ID cards and treat them
increasingly like Citizens We're
actually going to prohibit the law
enforcement agencies from enforcing the
law
and why are they doing this
they're doing this obviously because it
helps them politically but this is de
facto amnesty if you're if you're
telling the law enforcement agencies
they can't enforce the law on illegal
immigration and then you're giving the
illegal aliens government issued ID
cards that is de facto amnesty we know
that Biden and the Democrats want
amnesty at the federal level but they
don't they actually don't even need it
as you have this kind of breakdown of
the national sense of unity
you're just going to see these things
happen at the state level
and just as as far right as Texas or
Tennessee is going that's how far left
you're going to see California go you
know the rest of the show is continuing
right now you do not want to miss it if
you are a member
we are going to be getting to fake
headlines today I know it's it's woke
Wednesday we're supposed to get to a
woke commercial or or woke viral video
but I'm on the roads we're gonna swap it
this week okay we're gonna do the fake
headlines you've you've got to see if
you can guess which headline is fake
obviously we'll be chatting with you in
the daily wire remember Chad if you're
not already a member all right head on
over click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
[Music]